it's been three weeks since I got my Mac
Pro that's worth $15,000 and now for
those initial good feelings were off and
we did a ton of extensive testing I had
to ask myself was it really worth that
much money to be honest with you guys I
would have regretted it if it wasn't for
one specific thing I'll explain exactly
what and why in just a bit and also what
piece of new hardware makes this
computer a tough sell for me personally
now your use case might be different but
I'm already seeing some pro users for
grant buying one as well for some
reasons that you might not expect which
I'll also cover personally I have a few
hesitations with the system long term to
start off I save some money by
installing my own dram no I didn't go
for that insane 1 point 5 terabytes that
this Mac Pro is capable of but a mere a
hundred and ninety two gigabytes and
even then I saved over two thousand
dollars compared to buying from Apple
and if you're gonna buy one of these
aluminum beasts you should as well by
following our install guide that is
linked in the video description
when Apple announced this system it was
met with a ton of love for some people
while at the same time a bunch of hate
for me there were a lot of unanswered
questions that thankfully we were able
to uncover for our viewers and for
myself yes the graphics card is super
powerful as it should be for paying this
much money and yes compared to other
Intel workstations from other brands the
Mac Pro often cost less but with some
unique features and a much nicer build
the computer itself is glorious sure not
all are a fan of the cheese grater look
but it's definitely functional being
able to move a crazy amount of air and
get loud if it needs to for example if
you have a 28 core CPU with 4 graphics
cards and you're maxing out every single
component at the same time it could do
that without having any cooling issues
but at the same time it could be
completely silent for most uses my
config stayed silent even when you're
maxing out the CP using Cinebench and
the GPU with Unigine heaven at the same
time there are just three fans for
general cooling with no direct fans on
the graphics cards and they literally
stayed right around idle is a gaming
both with the LG 5k and also when we
finally got the super backordered
6kx dr and the vega to graphics card
performed better than we expected in
boot camp getting right around that
coveted consistent 60 FPS out ultra
settings in forza and that's at 5k
resolution which is pushing 15 million
pixels instead of 8 million in 4k we
also play call of duty at 6k resolution
which is over 20 million pixels and got
50 to 60 frames per second at medium
settings and trust us
6k at medium settings looks a fair bit
better than 4k at Ultra editing video
was also really amazing on this Mac I do
video production outside of YouTube and
we mostly work in Final Cut for speed
reasons so owning a Mac is required yes
there are hacking Tosh's which i've
actually built many of myself and i'm
gonna be doing another one soon using
thread Ripper to pit against this Mac
Pro but for daily professional work and
legal reasons I definitely prefer a true
Mac I connected to Mac Pro to our 112
tear by q-not with 10 Gigabit Ethernet
for video editing which works perfectly
out closer to a thousand megabytes a
second and since the Mac Pro has two of
these ports I ordered a new network hard
for our server and I'm excited to test
out link aggregation to get close to two
thousand megabytes per second so if
everything seems so good what is the
hesitation or regret well no it's not
the price even though it is very
expensive but for a well-functioning
business with employees a fifteen
thousand dollar computer that will last
many years is nothing compared to all
the other costs involved like taxes
insurance brand payroll benefits and
much much more
my issue is how much of this system is
being used when I'm doing my typical
video editing work in Final Cut Pro
there were some major changes and
software a few months ago and also some
new hardware releases that makes this
Mac Pro even more capable than it was
before that's a fantastic thing overall
but that also means that for some people
that really needed the performance of a
Mac Pro six months ago they may not need
it now let me explain a majority of our
video work uses various video in either
h.264 or HEV C formats
that's 4k up to 60 frames per second and
the Mac Pro choose through it so easily
in fact it is so
effortless that during playback of mixed
framerate footage with five layers of
color correction my CPU is only being
used at three percent and the graphics
card only hit a peak of 20% and keep in
mind I have a 12 core with a single
vector graphics card nothing near aspect
out model sure you might say that I
should have known that the system be a
bit overkill for that kind of work and
that is true but I didn't know it would
be this overkill in fact actually it
wouldn't have been this overkill if
Apple didn't recently rework final cuts
main engine and upgraded to metal
processing which dramatically improved
performance and yes when I am working
with tougher footage like C 200 RAW
files the CPU and the graphics are used
much more but even processing 4k 60
frames per second raw footage and
playing back files out full resolution
this lower-end Mac Pro is not maxed out
that is a huge kudos to Apple and their
software efficiency these kind of files
are something that I struggled with just
six months ago it made me very
interested in the new Mac Pro even at
these price points but now not only did
Apple greatly improve software but they
brought out a device that has been
incredibly successful so far
and that's the new 16 inch MacBook Pro
almost everybody that has bought one has
been very happy with it and the few
people that haven't are bothered by the
performance being too good but more on
that in another video
the base 16 inch MacBook Pro outperforms
the very best 2018 macro Pro and most
tasks and if you compare it to the base
2018 it obliterates it on the high end
it's just as impressive now offering
better CPU performance better graphics
performance with twice as much video
memory and now up to 64 gigabytes of RAM
as well as one key improvement that
could beat out a Mac Pro I've been
working with Mac books for years now
connected to my LG 5k display and it's
always been a trade-off in performance
to portability a part of that was not
enough CPU power but also being limited
in RAM and especially video memory with
the latest final cut it uses CPU power
much less than before and it really
leans into graphics which could be a bad
thing if you have a slow GPU but now
that we have the 5500 M with a gigabytes
of memory
this is no longer holding me back so
much so that when editing most of the
footage and final cut on an external
display it is hard to tell the
difference between the Mac Pro in the
MacBook Pro which is absolutely crazy
this would have been impossible without
this new MacBook Pro coming out and at
the same time having this new updated
software working together my bigger pain
points we're dealing with tougher
footage like raw video but with these
combined updates
I can now effortlessly edit my footage
with enough performance overhead for
color grading effects titles and other
stuff like that where I couldn't have
done that in the past and needed better
Hardware of course keep in mind that
this is with final cuts those that work
with Premiere Pro which are the biggest
group of editors won't have the same
luxury and the Mac Pro hardware will
really be needed and this amazing mac
pro pro isn't enough for a lot of those
users out there but that is because of
the really old inefficient engine and
plugins in Premiere Pro don't believe me
we'll check this out the MacBook Pro can
render a graded five-minute 4k raw 60fps
project in 10 minutes and 50 seconds
using Final Cut and if you're using my
much more powerful Mac Pro with premiere
it takes 25 minutes now rendering isn't
everything but even if you're editing in
a timeline this MacBook will playback
over 50 frames per second a full quality
whereas the Mac Pro and premier can only
do that at 24 frames per second because
of its inefficiency and to get better
results you would want a better
processor either maybe a 16 core or
higher this really shows how important
it is not only to have good Hardware but
it's even more important to have new
modern software that can make the best
use of it this is where my regrets start
coming in the new faster MacBook pairs
on my software that is so crazy
efficient means that I no longer need
hardware as powerful as a Mac Pro's in
order to have a fantastic video editing
experience like I did six months ago of
course there are still people who will
need more power but thanks to Apple that
market is now smaller now I mention that
there is one specific reason why I don't
regret getting a Mac Pro and that's
because we make videos like this one
where we don't earn any money on the
production but by having the hardware to
test
and make videos on not only do we earn
income but we also get to provide
knowledge and entertainment as well as
save a lot of people money with our
tests our comparisons our reviews and
also provide good suggestions to help
people get their right gear which makes
our Mac Pro purchase well worth it if it
wasn't for that I would regret buying
this aluminum beast not because it's not
good enough but thanks to Apple in their
new software it is too good for me and a
lot of other people where it wasn't just
six months ago I also mentioned
long-term meditations with this Mac Pro
for myself and others and that's because
there is a lack of PCI Express 4 and
also the CPU socket that's in here Apple
has been using Intel for many years now
and in the past four years they've
really been limited by Intel's constant
delays of 10 nanometer chips where AMD
is now serving amazing 7 nanometer
threat or adversity views I really hope
that Apple changes over to AMD or at
least offers an AMD Mac Pro but for now
it's just Intel which doesn't support
PCI Express 4 and also switches CPU
sockets much more frequently meaning
that future CPUs that come out may not
be supported in this computer now that
will mean big price drops on these
currency pews and those that want to
upgrade to a higher core count later
will be you know be able to do that much
cheaper but with the way software is
going if you're a Video Editor you don't
really need more powerful CPUs so there
you guys have it do I regret the Mac Pro
well no because on a business level
makes a whole lot of sense for us and
for those doing other kinds of work that
needs high end hardware with Mac OS it
makes sense as well because it's
actually cheaper than buying a high-end
iMac Pro and you get more power and more
ports and you also get upgrade ability
go ahead and let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and
check out our links in the video
description for the other kind of videos
and topics I talked about click up there
to subscribe and if you want to see some
other great videos there are a few right
over there
this Ben Max and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]